round up
whenever you have the option
to split some money
and you're trying to figure out
who gets more
because you don't have a exact way to
split it in half
always round up and give the other
person more
because you want to have the atmosphere
and feeling of generosity you want
people walking away from you feeling
like you're not only fair
but you're generous
when people think that you're generous
because you are generous then good
things come to you
and you don't do it because you're
expecting something in return you do it
to do it you do it because it's the
right thing to do
here's two quick examples of how i round
up sometimes i'll put on events
and at the events a lot of people will
pay with cash and i might split that
with somebody at the door
at the end of the night i'm counting
everything up and we're splitting you
know you create two different piles 20s
tens fives and you get down to it and
sometimes the money doesn't split up
exactly
and there might be five bucks
left over
i give it to him
and it's not from
a place of oh i've got so much money i
don't need this here you go you can have
it make them feel bad i just put it in
their pile you take it
it leaves them feeling happy
he wouldn't really care so much if i
took it
but you're kind of left with that
feeling of resentment like um
that evan took that last five bucks
they're not leaving super happy
where if you leave them with the extra
five bucks they're not on top of the
moon it's not going to save their life
but they're left feeling happier
here's another quick example i have a
cater
event at my office
for my mastermind meetings and the last
bill came in is something like 188
dollars and 20 cents
and i didn't have exact cash on hand to
pay my caterer he has his own shop
and i like supporting local
entrepreneurs i didn't have 188 20.
and i could have said
you know what i don't have the 20 cents
here's 188 it's okay right
and he would have taken it and he
probably would have been okay with it
but i don't want him walking away
feeling like there's a little bit even
that 20 cents creates a little bit of
resistance
so i gave him what i had i gave him 190
bucks
i don't care about the dollar 80 that i
overpaid for it it's what i had and i
was generous and i gave it to him
and then he's left feeling like evan is
a fair guy evan is a generous guy and
he's looking for ways to help me out
and if nothing ever comes back that's
fine too because it's the right thing to
do
so practice being generous and round up
if there's ever a situation where you
can't split something in half equally
give the other person a little bit more
you'll feel better they'll feel better
and more good things are coming to you i
can promise you
so practice rounding up
believe
you guys like this video
please give it a thumbs up below makes
want to do more and i want to hear what
you have to think do you round up right
now are you going to start rounding up
leave a comment below if you have a
question for your business leave it
underneath i'll do a video response i
really truly passionately love seeing
your comments come in so leave one below
thank you guys i'll see you soon